this freshly renovated villa from 1907
in a wealthy Berlin suburb is a listed
building registered historical landmark
it belongs to the state of Qatar and is
now the Embassy's Arab cultural house
the flags of Qatar and Germany in front
of the pediment don't just celebrate
friendship between the two countries
they also hide something the Emirates
conservative Muslim regime evidently
feels the need to keep out of sight a
half-naked woman in stone
neighbors are amused if indicates caring
narrow-minded weird friends be cool I
don't agree you can't cover our part
probably can see if I just don't
understand it but I guess it's up to the
owner well yes and no as a list of
building the villa can't be altered
without permission the question is
whether an awning constitutes an
alteration but that question is also
irrelevant since embassy properties are
extraterritorial meaning not subject to
local laws as Aisha can I know the
building well because I live nearby and
often go past it it's most laudable that
it's been renovated it was in a terrible
condition for many years
I shall not however address any possible
further issues move to schmooze me jaws
lesson on its homepage the embassy says
it's celebrating a year of culture in
Germany and the flags commemorate
cultural exchange and mark a celebration
of similarities as well as differences
there's no mention of the bone or rather
the breasts of contention